Oh welcome to dear Hank and John or as I
prefer to think of it Dear John and Hank
it's a comedy podcast about death
how're you doing John we've cut out all
the other channel the intro now we're
just a comedy podcast about death we're
not even gonna do Mars news no we're
doing it we're doing the AFC Wimbledon
news whether you like it or not I'm
doing alright it should be added that
Hank and I are in real life together
right now we are in Los Angeles for the
annual meeting of dftba.com our merch
company by the way if you have
merchandising needs if you want an oh my
god it's burning dear Hank and John
t-shirt for instance I thought you if
you have merchandising needs like you
need someone to merchandise like build
you Mart a merch line which we also do
sure yeah but in addition if you need
like shirts pants hats posters toasters
coffee mug wristbands coffee mugs FTB a
comm don't forget to be awesome
dftba.com your source for high quality
merch where you can brag about having
excellent taste in podcasts and other
media so we're having a great time
hanging out together I am doing well
mostly I have strep throat which isn't
ideal right yeah the strep throat I
can't recommend in good faith also Garry
Shandling just died
yeah and also like 30 other people this
has been a big death week it's been a
bad week for American celebrities and
also Toronto mayors and and Toronto
mayors former Mayor of Toronto Rob Ford
died Andy Grove the former CEO of Intel
died five dog one of my all-time
favorite rappers one of the absolute
lyrical geniuses of hip-hop in the 1990s
five dog who wrote I never need a statue
to tell me how nice I am who was part of
a movement within hip-hop to imagine a
world without forebears because none of
the forebears that they were told were
theirs felt like there's just an
absolute genius a member of tribe called
quest's that's a devastating loss and
then Garry Shandling if you like Modern
Family or the office or any show like it
you owe all of that to Garry Shandling
and his groundbreaking
show from the 1990s also just an
incredibly generous funny man gone from
this world at the age of 66 ah dang I
guess this is a comedy podcast about
death none of that was very funny but
that is that that is kind of the key to
good comedy is the funny part no it is
where it's not funny ever Garry
Shandling just and toward the end of his
life he didn't know he was dying he had
a sudden heart attack but he did an
interview with Jerry Seinfeld it
occurred to me by the way Hank that if I
suddenly die haha people will have lots
of quotes about my death to throw back
at me because it's been been such a
focus of my life that's true but you
won't care I might there's no way of
knowing for sure anyway point being
Garry Shandling in one of the last
interviews he did with Jerry Seinfeld
they did an episode of this great show
comedians comedians in cars getting
coffee correct and Garry Shandling said
that at his funeral he wants a boxing
referee who stands over his body and
says one two three four five and then
just waves his hands and calls it off
and says he's not getting up it's not
get that I'm pretty sure I just want
yeah I mean I mean I want to make sure
to make sure nobody's bearing me an ax
and a coffin in the ground and I'm still
alive I dunno that's key that's key yeah
there's nothing nothing I want less in
the world and you know who knows for
sure whether you're still breathing I'm
boxing a licensed referee of boxing
that's the kind of expert that I want to
attend to my death they are experts at
least in knowing if someone is conscious
or not I'm not so sure about alive and
dead I almost feel like we should move
on to the short poem for the day because
it's been so so dark it's sure I mean is
it is it gonna be less dark it is it is
now Hank as you know Richard Wright is
one of my favorite writers great
American novelist but he was also an
author of haiku in fact he wrote more
than 4,000 haikus in his life if we
wanted to we could have a short poem
every podcast for the next what I don't
know 40 years with nothing but Richard
Wright poems but I'm just gonna read you
one instead of reading you all 4,000 of
them it's a nice early spring poem an
apple blossom trembling on a sunlit
brain
from the weight of bees it's a haiku
number 78 by Richard right well John we
could have a richer day if we do in dear
Hank and John every week for the next 76
years young will still have Richard
write haikus I'll tell you my biggest
concern about that is that one or both
of us is almost certain to be deceased
in 76 years Wow don't you think so you
think oh yeah you think we're gonna die
no no I think I know we're gonna die I
think we're gonna die within the next 76
years no I think I'm gonna say both of
us are gonna be dead in 76 years I don't
only be a hundred fifteen huh that is on
the far it is on that's on the far edge
it'll likely curve the far outside of
that wave and and you know at 115 you're
riding that down down the the nether
regions of the bell curve they're
thinking things were okay like that
woman who did that dance with President
Obama nobody was happier than her ever
in the world that's true but I think she
was only 104 she's 11 years short of
being able to get through all of Richard
Wright's haikus you forget how much time
like you know like you get to be 17 you
know I got well at any any moment now
yeah really yeah and and then 90 is like
20 years from that yeah not like the
imagine all the stuff you get done
between when year zero is zero and 20
yes you get to do all that over again
right but in reverse order so instead of
you know getting potty-trained you find
yourself yeah yeah and suddenly I you
have to have you have to have caregivers
again no boy I don't we've just we've
gone all the way into the darkness and
what I wanted to do was read a nice
little spring haiku about bees so that I
could start off with a question for
Melissa nur about bees okay let's talk
about bees all right hang our first
question comes from Gabriella who asks
dear John and Hank I haven't heard about
the bees in a while are they okay or did
we just get bored with them best wishes
Gabriella like it it's not Gabriella you
do understand how how it all works in
the news media which is that if there's
a problem yeah and it goes on for long
enough yep it's like well that's not
news anymore there's not a new problem
just still a problem it's just a problem
yeah
and you don't talk about problems we
talk about new problems because it's
there's a reason we call it the news
yeah the B's are well according to my
morning walks here in Los Angeles
they're great they're everywhere they're
like this entire city smells like
flowers and the bees know it I saw a
hummingbird this morning which not a bee
I was gonna say I thought not not an
expert in ornithology but i believe
that's a bird and with a lot lots of
bees all over the place but I think that
the I think that colony collapse
disorder remains a problem and and we I
think that it's coming up on the season
where we sort of are able to know it's
been winter so it's sort of not be
season not really the the farming time
of the year and most of America though
here in California they just keep
growing stuff all the time so yeah we
it's a little less in the news because
we are not sure how it's going because
it's not B time so we're gonna find out
as we get into spring and then summer
we're gonna see how the bees are doing
bass you know compared to last year and
and whether or not we're gonna continue
to have you know crops food to eat stuff
like that I mean more important even
than that like imagine a future in which
that Richard write haiku just doesn't
make sense to readers because there are
no longer either apple blossoms or bees
I really read a book recently in which
something terrible happens and a person
has to remake the earth but with far
more solar radiation though this is a
fantasy not a science fiction and and so
they make all of the plants darker in
color and they make them sort of brown
and and everybody reads a literature
from the past and they're like could you
imagine a green plant what a ludicrous
color to apply to a plant yeah it'd be
like us thinking and about like purple
plants being like oh yeah well the whole
world is covered in neon purple plants
yeah what a what a lovely thing I'm
looking out the window of your hotel
here and I could see a bunch of trees of
all sorts palm trees oak trees other
trees yep de pine deciduous and
otherwise and what a nice car to have
the world covered in the nice edit must
be said uh Turley artificial as we are
currently in a desert Oh Los Angeles it
can handle it can handle the the trees
it's fine we'll just
but we'll get a big pipe bring it over
the mountains pipe all that water over
the mountains it's fine that'll work
Omega work we can do anything
we're I'm we're Americans we got another
question John this one's from Kat Karen
oh the drum piaced thing you've ever
said that's Z Rankin John what is the
most efficient way to stir my hot cocoa
Kara well Kara good news there is a
physics answer to this question is there
is you look this up yeah it involves
Brownian motion hmm it's the reason why
when you blow on your hot cocoa it
actually does cool it off faster than if
you don't know on it
I googled it and care a couple things
first off I don't understand why
stirring your hot cocoa makes it cooler
than it would otherwise be but it does
secondly this is not something that you
should worry about no no I think that
the the the what you should definitely
not do is use like a a like a two-stroke
lawnmower to stir your hot cocoa sure
inefficient yeah no you're right
actually that's a good point because you
don't want to add to your carbon
footprint when you're mixing your hot
cocoa so you don't want to do it in a
blender right right you you know make
sure you're not using a jet engine yeah
I would use I would use hand and spoon
or or one of those wooden stir sticks
but I probably just for the sake of the
environment use a reusable spoon oh yeah
I think the most efficient way to stir
your hot cocoa is with a spoon and your
hand do not I repeat do not involve
gasoline yeah or kerosene yeah in any
way yep just no engines yeah yeah I mean
if I I know Kara that you are profoundly
lazy don't you would like to use it okay
I totally disagree with your
characterization of Kara okay well all
right listen I've been reading I've been
reading cares questions on this very
podcast for months now and she's very
thoughtful interesting person and it's
not more than one Carol nope same Kara
and I believe it's actually it's
actually a Cara because I believe it's
actually
for 10 start Cara Delevigne she writes
in every week great friend of the pod
thanks car appreciate your support we've
got another question this one comes from
Sara and Jenna who write Dear John and
Hank we are wondering what you would
name a baby if you had to name it after
a fruit mmm there's some good fruits I
know
mango mango Roth Steelman steagle Monty
well the tea yeah well first off I mean
I think this would be your baby
so it would be mango green which is a
terrible name mango green is a horrible
name to give a child well lime green is
worse lime green is bad olive green is
actually pretty cute olive green is kind
of adorable I might go with all of if
and olive is a fruit which I'm not sure
it is how does a fruit doesn't taste
like a fruit what else would an olive be
mmm I don't even think that an olive is
a food I've had this argument with my
wife for years I'm actually with you on
it I think it's more of like it's more
of like a food additive yeah it's like a
garnish yeah right it's more like
parsley which I also don't think of as a
fruit
oh well that's clearly not a fruit cut
out some leaves
I'd also don't think of it as a
vegetable I think of it as a sort of
non-food item that sometimes accompanies
food well parsley is particularly
ludicrous because it doesn't even have
flavor it's just it's it's literally
there just to have to give you a look if
you will at least parse there's a little
bit of flavor but I don't think that we
really need to get into the weeds of
that that question because it doesn't
address the larger question from Sarah
and Jenna which is what would you name
your child if you had to name it after a
fruit I'm gonna go with olive I came up
with a great answer that's adorable
named olive green what the Frick I think
I'm gonna go with Kiwi that's cute too
Kiwi green mm-hmm
I like Kiwi green yeah I mean I think
it's gonna be hard to lose Sarah and
Jenna one thing that I would say is I
would not go with rectangular banana
mint angular banana green or triangular
banana we've seen a few triangular
bananas from from some Hank and dear
Hank and John listeners we really
appreciate ya thank you for seeing us
all your bananas on Twitter I do want to
say that it might be
good idea and I was talking about this
on not too deep with a grace Helbig
which is yep we're gonna come out
significantly after this podcast sure
so I'm spoiling it for you okay that
it's good to name your child something
something that's already in the emoji
Bank oh that's a great point so that you
don't have to type out the whole name
and they can just put the emoji on their
birth certificate yeah it's actually
ideally ideally you'll name your child
some kind of emoji right
I wonder what like if you had to pick
from an emoji what you would pick for a
real name not like a joke name like
obviously you know obviously we'd all be
tempted by praise hands green yeah but
like what would you actually pick it's
funny that is the example I used I'm not
really yeah yeah well or you know and
everybody would say that they're gonna
do smiling pile of poo green but nobody
you know we like nobody actually no no
of course not yeah I'm opening up my
emojis now like what's a good what's a
good nay alien face eyeballs zucchini
green bikini green diamond ring diamond
ring green caterpillar caterpillar green
suit okay clovers gonna go for green
yeah work yeah sure
tulips let me take a look at that emoji
Bank I don't actually don't have emojis
on my phone that's how old I am yes
they've got apple apple green eggplant
eggplant right like like go to filters
lollipop green that's a little weird
it's cute baby bottle green if that's
like really cute at first but then it's
like progressively less useful you know
like being called a baby bottle green
when you're a 32 year old executive at
like a large tech firm then you just you
just be be you could be be be green we
actually have a cousin be be golfing
green golfing golfing greens that person
yeah the person is golfing it's a
conference of golfing golfing green
tennis green this green is a thing I'm
pretty pleased with yellow ribbon green
and then I think I would go with purple
Space Invader green if I had to actually
make a choice I've got a purple Space
Invader green I didn't know there was a
space invader good it would just be like
flag of Japan green to 30 green to got
the clock right yeah yeah 2:30 to 3:00
alright this is a stupidest thing we've
ever done on this podcast and that's
really saying because I'm totally
ruining the great jokes that mean grace
made about this
yeah yeah all right Hank so we got a lot
a lot a lot a lot of questions this week
about Donald Trump oh I bet we did it's
the thing where no matter what you're
doing what you're talking about it just
comes up like you're like it's enough
that 90% of the news is Donald Trump
could could not 90% of my life meet
Donald Trump please you know Hank it's
funny I was thinking about an old line
often falsely attributed to George
Bernard Shaw it's not really clear its
provenance but it is a wonderful
wonderful observation and seems to me to
speak to our time brilliantly the line
is this never wrestle with a pig you get
dirty and besides the pig likes it I
think when it comes to Donald Trump all
you get when wrestling the pig is dirty
and all Donald Trump gets is stronger I
I have not seen any evidence that
pointing out that Donald Trump is not
qualified to be President of the United
States on many different levels has
resulted in any cracks in his support so
we're trying to figure out how to best
engage with that in online discourse but
this question comes from Eric and it's
an interesting one he writes Dear John
and Hank we need to have a serious
discussion about politics with the
entirety of nerdfighteria okay I don't
know that that's actually possible Eric
because you know nerdfighter is sort of
and it's like an amoeba it's an
amorphous blob of more four different
kinds of people it's an amorphous blob
and and of people who people with
shifting identities we can disagree on
tax rates on minimum wages on how much
the US government should intervene in
different things and you're right that
this is a conversation we need to have
peacefully and respectfully but we also
need to set boundaries you can't expect
me to respect the opinion of someone who
believes that gay marriage is wrong and
should be illegal or treat as legitimate
the claim that global warming isn't a
huge man-made problem yet those are the
viewpoints of all three main Republican
candidates so this is a difficult
difficult thing and like I have the same
problem I have the same problem and and
but I at the same time want to be able
to not hate
these people like well for me it's for
me it's what's gonna what's gonna work
I'm not interested in like the Maya
right right well there's there is like
yes I see what you're saying but like
it's yes yeah I think you're right I
think what's yeah you continue talking
because I I'm doing poorly so in my
opinion removing people from the
conversation or excluding them from the
conversation does not lead to change so
making it so that people don't feel
comfortable in a space that all that
means is that they're going to seek out
other spaces where they won't be
challenged on those topics they're going
to seek out their echo chambers and
that's true for all of us by the way not
just not just people who don't think
that climate change is man-made which it
is and so the challenge for me is how do
I engage in conversations where I state
strongly that you know obviously I
believe that in marriage equality I
believe that there's a massive
overwhelming amount of evidence that
climate change is caused by humans and
how do I say that and acknowledge that
and make that part of my worldview while
at the same time not excluding other
people from the conversation which in
the end will get me less will get me
further and further away from what I
want which is people who can engage
seriously with each other on these
topics because I really believe that if
you engage seriously you think seriously
and you look at the evidence when it
comes to climate change or when it comes
to marriage equality it the argument
goes away the legitimacy of the
anti-marriage equality argument goes
away and the legitimacy of the anti
global warming is a real thing that that
goes away too
yeah I mean it's difficult to have
compassion for people when you feel a
little bit like the source of their
perspective contains not so much
compassion but it is it's important to
remember that people are very different
from each other I have a little bit more
sympathy for the global warming thing
because it's like okay fine whatever
maybe you feel like this is all like
just a liberal plot
take to like increase the size of
government and like sure that's scary
but like the denial of people's rights
just seems very an American but it is
obviously a thing that we did for the
last 200 years and and it is terrifying
that we've done that and so I try to
have sympathy I tried to have be
compassionate and and think hard about
like and like understand that people
have different perspectives they mean
that does not make them bad people it
makes that but it makes their beliefs
bad but it does not make them bad and
and I'm reminded of a lion from from
Ender's Game which I just looked up and
did not have this in my head in the
moment when I truly understand my enemy
understand him well enough to defeat him
then in that very moment I also loved
him and a particularly poignant because
the author of Ender's Game is kind of ya
know I think yeah so the other the other
thing the other thing I'd add here is
that I have seen a lot in YouTube
comments and and just generally in the
way that we're talking people saying
look what's happened to this great
country look how horrible things have
become in the United States this once
great nation and I think that calls back
to a past that just did not exist right
I mean for the vast majority of American
history women couldn't vote for much of
American history
white men couldn't vote unless they were
rich enough to own property for the vast
majority of American history African
African American men couldn't vote I
mean for the vast majority of America's
history it has been a profoundly
undemocratic place like in 1960 as late
as 1968 most delegates who chose the
nominees for the political parties were
not beholden to voters in any way and
that's changed and that's good the
United States has become a more
inclusive country when it comes to
governance in the last 50 years and in
the last 100 years and in the last 200
years and I just don't buy that there's
a place in American history that you can
point to that was some golden age like
yeah we are a deeply flawed country but
we always have been that's all clearly
just you know psychology and that's how
feel and about the world in it and we're
pointing out not that this harkening
back isn't isn't pointing out a
legitimate like thing that we're
remembering its point it's it's just
connecting with people's emotions and
that's a lot of what this is about and I
think that I think a lot of you know
like and then you get into like trying
to figure out the psychology of every
person who's supporting Donald Trump
when every person who's supporting
Donald Trump has different psychology
different ideology and different reasons
why they're doing it some people just
are just racist some people are excited
about a legitimate businessman in office
even though it's not what I would call a
legitimate businessman or in fact a
successful one and and some people are
just like a hundred percent protest vote
because the Republican Party tried to
spread itself a little too thin in how
and how it appealed to voters and
clearly a lot of people got
disenfranchised by that process so I
think the other thing that Eric wanted
to point out is that you know we talk a
lot about trump and trumpism but Ted
Cruz and Marco Rubio and hold in many
cases very similar viewpoints
ideological especially when it comes to
climate change and marriage equality and
a few other a few other things that are
important to a lot of a lot of a lot of
voters and that and that are sort of in
my opinion at least openly
discriminatory and and that's that is an
important thing to note like you can't
you can't sort of ridicule trumpism
without also noting that it is part of a
much larger strain of ideology within
within the Republican Party that has in
many cases broad support among
Republicans and I think that but I don't
think the way I don't think the way to
counter that is with is merely with
anger or without rage I think the way to
encounter it is to try to listen to
people and to try to understand them and
then to defend your point of view you
know passionately and and with
seriousness yeah and and I yeah we look
at we look at this and a lot of this is
driven in fact by
people objectifying their opponent and
it is ludicrous to say that we do not do
that we as liberals as Democrats we do
that all the time
I'm not gonna Kratt well as or as well
or as like whatever let's just got
awkward
however we are it's like all sides do
that we love to demonize our opponents
and we're good at it and it is it's it
is the reason why a lot of and it's been
sort of like a joyous thing to ridicule
them as a Democrat as a referral for the
last eight years because there's been a
guy that I like quite a bit in the White
House and that like probably didn't do
us any any favors in the long term the
ridiculing him in yeah the ridiculing
yeah not not the presidency which I
quite enjoyed the last thing that I want
to say is I yeah i think that we end up
looking at this as as like a team sport
and like we're rooting for our team and
we kind of and even like we disengage
from from policy and talk lonely about
ideology and about who's who's bad and
who's who's wrong and I think that I
have just I've I've started to feel more
than ever in the last the last few
months that it's really important to
think of this country as a country and
and that may be governing it is more
important than winning and I don't know
that anybody in politics is feeling that
right now that was very beautifully put
Hank let's try to have more policy
discussions on dear Hank and John
instead of ideology discussions I'd love
to have a question about what we think
the top marginal income tax rates should
be for instance well I've got one here
from Robin that is is some somewhat
similar who asks dear Hank and John is
Kanye West cocky or confident alright so
I have a lot of opinions on this I don't
know maybe we just skip it maybe there's
too much I don't I don't know do we have
a whole episode to devote to the
question there's there's some things
that I consider myself like something of
an expert in young adult fiction the
sort of yeah ethics around conjoined
twins
there's a few things that I've done a
lot of reading about there is nothing
that I have thought so long and so hard
about like Kanye's confident slash
cockiness so you should watch Sara's
video the case for Kanye West where she
makes the case for him as a contemporary
artist whose work is in many ways a kind
of performance art I think that Kanye is
often a buffoon he is often wrong he is
often offensive he does also often
apologize for being wrong and a buffoon
and defensive which is something that
you don't see enough these days I love a
good apologizer
he is a provocateur he understands that
in the contemporary media landscape
being provocative is in many ways more
valuable than being great and he is also
a brilliant brilliant manipulator of
contemporary discourse and media and I
think that he is confident but I also
think that he plays cocky because he
understands what he understands both the
threats and opportunities posed by this
image of a cocky african-american strong
male and I think he's plays with our
expectations around that and so I think
it's not a matter of being cocky or
confident it's a matter of transcending
both cockiness and confidence in the
pursuit of something else that he wants
that's much more interesting and do you
think that that is the thing that Kanye
wants West once only for Kanye West or
is that something bigger than that no I
think Kanye West is trying to make a
bunch of points to all of us about about
celebrity about media worship and about
the way that we treat and imagine and
look at black bodies in media and in
public conversations I also think that
Kanye West is trying to do what's good
for Kanye West and I think that there is
an amazing and sometimes unproductive
tension there and I would love for Kanye
to be to be able to let go of what's
good for Kanye
do you think that we could have him on
the podcast do you think we can get
could Kanye on the pad get him a little
dear Hank and John maybe he could bring
some news from from Neptune so here's
where would he bring the news from
here's here's my closest connection to
Kanye oh you have a close connection to
Kanye I look at you you hanging out with
Taylor Swift Kanye West's right around
the corner I am uh I am acquainted with
Kendall and Kylie Jenner
oh I'm acquainted with Kanye West's
agent oh well yeah why don't we just
call why don't we just call him actually
go out we know Kanye West's agent just
called yeah I'll just text him right now
yeah just be like hey can you get Kanye
on our pod yeah the three hundred and
seventy third most popular podcast on
iTunes today I and we we talked and I
wanna I want to ask Kanye his opinions
on death mostly I just want to know how
I feel oh the impending demise of Kanye
West I would Inc that will happen I
would be fascinated to hear what whether
Kanye West thinks about death and
whether it haunts him at night oh why do
you think why else is he doing all this
stuff well why else it's all about
everybody's driven by the same thing
John no I don't buy that argument at all
because I actually don't buy it at all
because I'm not driven by death the way
that you are I'm not driven by death at
all because I have I don't labor under
the delusion that somehow like work that
I do will survive me in ways that will
allow me to like somehow escape the
universality of death about death I
don't think you're always thinking about
death you don't think about death I very
rarely think about death really yeah
like your own death or other people's I
think about other people's death far
more than think about my own I would
estimate that I think about my death I
mean you think about it every day right
no you go a whole day without thinking
about your death I would say that 90% of
the times I think about death is while
we're recording dreg good job are you
serious yeah so I understand that like
my rumination and obsession with my own
mortality is like an outgrowth of my
obsessive compulsive disorder because I
recognize those thought spirals as being
very similar to the other thought
spirals that I get into yeah but at the
same time it seems to me the only one
that isn't crazy like I
I understand like like when I look at
the sort of like my OCD like I see
behaviors and I'm like those are not
normal like I you know like that is a
that is a mental health problem but I
don't feel that way about my obsession
with death at all it feels totally
adorable sorry
well I don't know people are gonna have
to let us know and it comes from the
soundcloud and at the patreon patreon
calm so I should you're Hank and John do
you think about death every day
boy today's podcast is really brought to
you by death cold dead senseless
meaningless death night is everywhere
not for the first time is it brought to
you by death either today's podcast is
also brought to you by 2-stroke cocoa
stirrers powered by gasoline mixed with
motor oil they just posted right down in
there india cocoa and give it give it a
pull oh it's so so efficient and of
course this podcast is brought to you by
death death it's coming for you it's
coming for you and it will not be denied
Oh and finally if this podcast is
brought to you by the end of a healthy
American political discourse
welcome to the terrible future healthy
political discourse no longer extent
hide in the United States just don't
think we had a past with healthy
political discourse I just you realize
we had a civil war we didn't act like
people killed each other on a
battlefield over bad political discourse
it's true it's true and I don't think
that people are gonna kill each other on
a battlefield no we are not gonna have a
civil war now
yeah it's nice it's nice I'm glad to be
there I'm glad to be though I was
talking to a person who's an expert and
who has done mediation for several
actual wars like people on both sides of
actual wars
he was like none of the other places I
went to thought that it could happen to
their country haha I was like shut up
and stop talking to me I don't want to
know don't tell me about how any of that
we've got a question from Jason John Jay
yes dear Hank and John what are your
thoughts on JC Penney's penny days sale
where many of the products have a buy
one get one for a penny sale i person
we feel very upset by this well here's
what I'll say Jason it isn't a buy one
get one for a penny sale it's a buy one
get one free sale because pennies are
worth nothing so this way is this the
thing that's upset upsetting you I
assume so yeah I assume it's the fact
that it just calls attention to the
worthlessness of the penny I mean in
this in this moment JC Penney's is
essentially saying mmhmm this is such a
good deal that we will give you the
second item for not nothing but we will
take away something that is worth less
than nothing we will take away this
thing that you might have that's worse
less worth less than nothing
as a kind of charitable endeavor we will
take your pennies away from you i all
love the idea of a place that like it's
like the sale is bring us your pennies
and we'll take them that's the whole
sale and then you can buy things as well
can I tell you the the business I hate
most in the entire world
coin store really do you know coin star
is a publicly traded stock you can buy
coin star stock on a stock exchange well
I won't because this is coin stars
business model coin stars business model
is coins are so worthless they are such
a bad example of what money ought to do
which is facilitate the exchange of
goods and services that we what we'll do
is you throw all of your coins into our
machine and all we're going to do is
take away 7 percent of the value of your
money in exchange for giving you you
know money in a different form yeah that
you can finally use to spend it is an
elude Icarus it is a ludicrous thing
that exists but but I do there's a thing
that I very much liked about coin star
hmm if you go this is a thing if you go
to a coin star there's a little there's
there's like a mesh thing yeah that sure
the smallest one is a little bit smaller
than a dime yeah and then you lift it up
and they all slide in what happens is
all the stuff that isn't like that is in
like
like a cardboard box full of coins yeah
all the stuff that isn't coins falls
through that and just into a tray yeah
and so you can stick your head in there
and look down and see all the stuff that
people had in their weird cardboard
boxes full of coins and it's always
fascinating to find out what's in there
yeah so great and you just look down in
there and there's like look at all that
stuff look at all that stuff that people
have in their boxes full of coins that
doesn't give me any fulfillment film it
is if we had rational money-making that
focused on huh sure what could we do but
to make would our money useful to the
people on earth who spend it what would
give me the same thrill though if we got
rid of coins traffic got at all this we
made all the things the policies make
sense what would give me that thrill
where would I go for that what's in
people's coin boxes thrill now you go
over to your friend's house you open up
their medicine cabinet it's duly
fascinating yet the exact same joy
that's awful John don't do that
I do it every time I visit who that if
I'm not your ass you can rest assured
that when I go to your bathroom I take a
quick glance man I got put on my
suppositories in the under Thunder
compartment I have a secret compartment
the back your medicine cabinet you open
up medicine get in the opening yeah back
of the medicine cabinet and you just
reach in the other room where you grab
your friends hair and they're like it's
great fun we've got another question hey
I don't this the the podcast is so far
off the rails that I don't know how to
get it back on the rails but this
question comes from Anna uh-huh I think
the frozen character but I'm not
positive okay um and she writes dear
John and Hank my friends and I have been
discussing the consequences of loosing
your big toe they've been telling me
that you would have a lot of double
without reading spelling John I'm not
making fun of their spelling I think
they mean if it became loose loosening
just twisting it like three is not like
twisting in a few times not like full
full removal but just like like but I
like the top of a coke can yeah like
what if your toe just a little bottle
yeah it's loosened yeah if it was
slightly loosened no so Anna I feel that
this is an important moment in our
relationship losing has only 100 in it
loosing which is also a word has two O's
in it but I think you meant losing
losing your big toe they've been telling
me that you'd have a lot of trouble
walking if this happened so what would
actually
happen if you washed your big toe would
your life be that different yes it would
be hard to walk and it would be very
hard to dance in particular I think
running you just just play a little bit
here's an idea take a take a pebble like
some kind of uncomfortably sized pebble
and tape it like scotch tape it to the
bottom of your big toe yeah and every
time you feel that pebble as you walk
around think I would not be able to put
pressure on that place mm-hmm
and imagine how it would feel to walk
around you yeah your big toe does a
great deal of work you can it is it is
connected to a large tendon that's
connected to your calf muscle it's one
of the one of the muscles in your calf
controls your big toe and it's a fairly
large muscle and it does a lot of work
you do not want to not have that thing
to do that pushing from a functional
standpoint according to a study
published in clinical orthopedics and
related research amputating a big toe
results in little or no disability so
everything that you just said is wrong
at least at least according to clinical
orthopedics and related research which I
don't know if that's a better source
than your thing about putting a pebble
on your toe but I kind of suspect that
it is so it will affect your gait but it
will not result in your it will not
result in you being unable to run sure
no yeah you would yes and in the in the
beginning it would be much more
difficult you'd get better at using it
but I do think that if you were if you
really enjoy dancing it would definitely
impact your ability to dance I I
actually have a lot of toe pain in my
and my pinky toe on my right foot I mean
this must be the seventh podcast where
you've mentioned that I often wish that
I could have it amputated but I've been
told that it would it would impact my my
ability to have a good time on the dance
floor yeah John you know what I how I
feel about this podcast today how a
little bit a little bit disorganized a
little disconnected maybe not maybe not
the smoothest one we've ever done no
Reid I feel like we gave no what no
dubious advice at all none whatsoever
absolutely zero and and we talked about
my least favorite topic which is Donald
Trump this is what I just want to not
ever do it and yet there we did we did
it John
well I don't think we'll be doing it
again so
I hope that I hope that those of you who
wanted us to do that are satisfied
because I don't I can't see us going
back to it at least not in the short run
I just don't want to do what I want to
do which is to make myself feel soup
like talk talk to a bunch of people
about how superior we are to a bunch of
people who do believe different things
than us or like support different things
than us and I'm like no that's just
that's just more of the bad thing where
we all talk about how much better we are
than other people I don't know what you
just said but I feel dirty and I feel
like the pig-like did all right it's
time for the news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon John should i do Mars first
sure all right I'm gonna do Mars first
the news from Mars nASA has released a
lovely gravity map of Mars showing all
the gravitational differences in the
different areas of the Martian surface
also it tells us some stuff about the
interior of Mars it's a very pretty
image you could just google and I'm sure
you'll find it and you from these
gravitational differences we can tell
some different new things about Mars we
can see the effects of the massive
Tharsis volcanoes when they erupted and
and like basically crushed down the
Martian crust crushed down the crust we
can see constant sublimation and
condensation of co2 at the at the poles
and we can see how much that all of the
massive amount trillions of tons of co2
is is affecting the gravity of Mars and
also we can tell that Mars as we
suspected from I think a study back in
like ten years ago that Mars actually
has a liquid outer core just like Earth
so so Earth has like a solid inner core
and then a liquid mantle and then a you
know the crust and so we think that Mars
has also a liquid outer core which
raises the question why if it does does
it not have a magnetic field because
because the gas because the inner core
inside of this liquid core the solid
inner core isn't spinning for whatever
reason and if it were it would become
very different planet Mars would be
probably potentially a planet with a lot
more surface water so raising a lot of
questions about Mars and also answering
some questions and a fascinating
fascinating image you should check out
because it's pretty and you can see how
just also the
like tremendous effects of Mars's large
massive volcanoes biggest volcanoes in
the solar system and and also best
volcanoes in the source because
everybody knows Mars the best John
what's your news well Mars is not the
best because AFC Wimbledon is the best
tanked have you ever read Tale of Two
Cities by Charles Dickens Scott have you
it was the best of times and the worst
of times now I have it I just I just
think maybe that's all I needed
that's all I needed you to say okay I
haven't read the book it was the best of
times Charles Dickens he's the one with
like Tiny Tim and it was the worst of
times oh it's good in bad news it was
the worst of times
oh it was but now it's the best no
unfortunately it remains the worst of
times because AFC Wimbledon
you'll recall Hank their new stadium
going home to Wimbledon back to plough
Lane it was unanimously approved by the
Merton Planning Council until yesterday
when London Mayor Boris Johnson decided
that all that was even elected decided
that all of that was irrelevant and that
by the way if you want to see a picture
of what an English Donald Trump would
look like Google Boris Johnson Boris
Johnson he also hates love and joy and
happiness he he called the he called the
stadium plan in and now there is going
to be a second hearing wimbledon will it
is not an end wimbledon will continue to
push for a new stadium and it may well
happen but it will probably be the work
of the next mayor so that is the
discouraging news and it is really
discouraging because of course you know
the AFC Wimbledon's long term plans to
return to their you know to return to
their neighborhood to be back at plough
Lane you know it was looking great and
now it's looking slightly less great and
yet it was the best of times oh it was
the best of times because down one nil
against bottom of the league York City
AFC Wimbledon were we're basically in a
position Hank seventy minutes into the
game down one nil to the world team in
the way
Wow they were basically in a position
where it just the playoff dream was dead
and then there was an own-goal my
favorite kind of goal it's the
equivalent of a game being won by
waterlogged pitch an own-goal just a
beautiful thing and this was a beautiful
goal and then in the third minute of
three minutes of stoppage time Jake
Reeves Hank I believe I've shown you the
goal you have I saw that you go and
people should go Google the goal go to
go look at AFC wimbledon vs york
highlights on the youtube because this
is astonishing here's a nice goal in the
last minute of the game jake reeves
takes the ball down on his chest from 30
yards outside and he loops in a
ridiculous volley it's like it curves
it's like it says to the air i'm not so
sure about how you work it I've decided
that you're gonna work this way today
it was a wiffle ball it was of a goal it
was and I liked how he kicks it he's
sort of like it was like Jake Reeves not
our best player but a star a solid a
solid English fourth tier professional
soccer player in the last moment of the
game chested the ball down and thought
to himself maybe I should do that thing
I know how to do yeah and then proceeded
to do it yeah you hit the very upper
left hand corner of both the crossbar
and the post as the ball goes into the
net from 30 yards out but first I'll
kick it so high that it's like 700 feet
above the air above the air yeah it's
not even in the atmosphere it's in outer
space but then thank God the forces of
gravity are such that it was returned
from near-earth orbit to the goal and
Wimbledon 1 2 1 1 nil down to 2 1 oh
that's that's the way we're gonna win
the cup you get for winning the playoffs
I am I am very excited we've got
Hartlepool next also a bit of a bottom
dweller Hartlepool and once saw them
play Swindon Town they weren't
particularly impressive but did get a
draw and Hartlepool next and then just 8
games remain in AFC Wimbledon season
it's been a great season
if very frustrating for this news from
London's mayor I really think you should
google him by the way he is he is
something to look at and you see what I
mean
oh wow I know he looks like he looks
like the the guy in the pit of despair
from from Princess Bride he does a
little bit well he made a bad decision
but yeah so if there is darkness there
is light and and ever the two shall
coexist long may they both reign AFC
Wimbledon Hartlepool tomorrow or
yesterday as you're watching this
listening to this yeah big game big big
game alright John we've got a couple of
a couple of updates from from the from
the community out there we got one Hank
if you ever come to California which I'm
in California right now you can eat it
in an out burger and enjoy some sesame
seed free burger buns
I knew this about in-n-out burger and so
one of the things I love about in and
out and I love it uh thank you very much
for the tip and I'm sure I'll get to in
and out while I'm out here though I'm
trying not to eat it every day oh I
wanted to do this just this other one
from Rachael okay go and we also and we
also have this from Rachael who says AFC
Wimbledon is playing in the same league
as Stephen of Stevenage FC and Stevenage
is the town where the ESA ExoMars Rover
companion to the recent ExoMars launch
is being designed and built so maybe I
should become a Stevenage fan John no no
no no when was Hank
when was the last time you played
Stevenage is there stuff what first I
was wrong with Stevenage I mean and I
say this with great immense respect for
Rachel you don't want to be a Steven I'm
not well for one thing their 22nd in
league - well does that mean that
they're not gonna be an elite - next
year that means there's a reasonable
chance that next year you could be
supporting a semi-professional club but
I believe in them though I believe in
them John and that's what it's about
take you know what if you want to become
a Stevenage fan and you
to have the Hank green stand at
Stevenage Stadium which is called
broad hallway and you want to and you
want to like have the you want to be a
fan of the boar oh that's what they're
called Vivaro is the nickname of the
different because they're from a borough
like every other club in in a league -
yeah you can you could be a Stevenage
supporter and I you know what I would
support you completely I think that that
would be great it would be great for
both of us just so you know we're
Stevenage is it's it's there it's in
this part of London our English it's in
part of but it's pretty near London it
looks like it's London ish yeah I'm not
an expert I am also not what you would
call an expert on the local geographies
of it's about 30 miles north of central
London the UK
hake I would rather you be an AFC
Wimbledon supporter than a Stevenage
supporter but I would rather you be a
Stevenage supporter then not understand
the beauty of football at all all right
well I would rather you be a Venus
supportive and not understand the beauty
of the exploration of our solar system
at all all right thanks so what did we
learn today we learned that you think
mostly most of your time has spent
thinking about either death or Kanye
West that's completely untrue it
underestimates how much time I spend
thinking about AFC Wimbledon all right
you got the three things John the three
things and of course we learned that it
is not efficient to stir your hot cocoa
using a lawnmower no absolutely not it's
also a very efficient to get your
merchandise needs fulfilled at dftba.com
we have oh my god it's burning shirts
and and shirts and mugs and lots of
other stuff available at dftba.com our
only actual podcast sponsor and of
course we learned that if Hank had the
name of baby after a fruit he would name
it olive green help raise hands map of
Japan flag of Japan Jon Japan green oh
man what a future that kid would have
what's your name flag that's a weird
name what's your full name so I give
Japan green this is so easy it is the
mochi that birth certificate up all
right John we got I am the proud nation
of Brazil green
Oh difficult times in Brazil John the
thank you for listening to our podcast
thank you for performing in this podcast
with me John I was an excellent
performance I'm glad you read your lines
so so professional if they were not
written at all well Hank it's been a
pleasure as always to spend an hour in
your company even if the recorder had to
be on for this hour our podcast is
edited by Nicholas Jenkins our intern is
Claudia Morales was he on a hospital
house helps us out a lot with questions
and many other things there are theme
music is by gunnarolla and as we say in
our hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]